[Music]
picture warm gooey cookies crunchy
candies velvety cakes waffle cones piled
high with ice cream is your mouth
watering are you craving dessert
why what happens in the brain that makes
sugary foods so hard to resist sugar is
a general term used to describe a class
of molecules called carbohydrates and
it's found in a wide variety of food and
drink just check the labels on sweet
products you buy glucose fructose
sucrose maltose lactose dextrose and
starch are all forms of sugar so are
high fructose corn syrup fruit juice raw
sugar and honey and sugar isn't just in
candies and desserts it's also added to
tomato sauce yogurt dried fruit flavored
waters or granola bars since sugar is
everywhere it's important to understand
how it affects the brain what happens
when sugar hits your tongue and does
eating a little bit of sugar make you
crave more you take a bite of cereal the
sugars it contains activate the sweet
taste receptors part of the taste buds
on the tongue these receptors send a
signal up to the brain stem and from
there it Forks off into many areas of
the forebrain one of which is the
cerebral cortex different sections of
the cerebral cortex process different
tastes bitter salty umami and in our
case sweet from here the signal
activates the brain's reward system this
reward system is a series of electrical
and chemical pathways across several
different regions of the brain it's a
complicated Network but it helps answer
a single subconscious question should I
do that again that warm fuzzy feeling
you get when you taste grandma's
chocolate cake that's your reward system
saying mmm yes and it's not just
activated by food socializing sexual
behavior and drugs are just a few
examples of things and experiences that
also activate the reward system but over
activating this reward system kick
starts a series of unfortunate events
loss of control craving and increased
tolerance to sugar let's get back to our
bite of cereal it travels down into your
stomach and event
into your gut and guess what there are
sugar receptors here too
they're not taste buds but they do send
signals telling your brain that you're
full or that your body should produce
more insulin to deal with the extra
sugar you're eating the major currency
of our reward system is dopamine an
important chemical or neurotransmitter
there are many dopamine receptors in the
forebrain but they're not evenly
distributed certain areas contain dense
clusters of receptors and these dopamine
hotspots are a part of our reward system
drugs like alcohol nicotine or heroin
send dopamine into overdrive leading
some people to constantly seek that high
in other words to be addicted sugar also
causes dopamine to be released though
not as violently as drugs and sugar is a
rare among dopamine inducing foods
broccoli for example has no effect which
probably explains why it's so hard to
get kids to eat their veggies speaking
of healthy foods let's say you're hungry
and decide to eat a balanced meal you do
and dopamine levels spike in the reward
system hot spots but if you eat that
same dish many days in a row dopamine
levels will spike less and less
eventually leveling out that's because
when it comes to food the brain evolved
to pay special attention to new or
different tastes why two reasons first
to detect food that's gone bad and
second because the more variety we have
in our diet the more likely we are to
get all the nutrients we need to keep
that variety up we need to be able to
recognize a new food and more
importantly we need to want to keep
eating new foods and that's why the
dopamine levels off when a food becomes
boring now back to that meal what
happens if in place of the healthy
balanced dish you eat sugar rich food
instead if you rarely eat sugar or don't
eat much at a time the effect is similar
to that of the balanced meal but if you
eat too much the dopamine response does
not level out in other words eating lots
of sugar will continue to feel rewarding
in this way sugar behaves a little bit
like a drug it's one reason people seem
to be hooked on sugary foods
so think back to all those different
kinds of sugar each one is unique but
every time any sugar is consumed it
kick-starts a domino effect in the brain
that sparks a rewarding feeling too much
too often and things can go into
overdrive
so yes overconsumption of sugar can have
addictive effects on the brain but a
wedge of cake once in a while won't hurt
you